hey guys so as you can tell I'm having a
pretty rough night with my skin
um
this is it is not very happy Millie
Bobby Brown no stranger to skin
imperfections been coming to times with
it slowly the actress gets real about
her struggles with acne and a new makeup
free video These pimples up here are not
happy this one right here isn't
um I think they're hormonal and then for
this one that just looks really angry
with me
to put one of our stickers on there some
tea tree oil spot stickers to just give
that the love it needs I'm actually just
never seen before double up on them
um because it's kind of the surrounding
areas that are also really unhappy with
me
so I have done whales
fans flooded Millie's comment section
praising her honesty one writes so brave
for posting this while another says love
how she shows her imperfections like a
normal person because some people think
that famous people don't have this
struggle I feel like you know we
accomplished that Millie isn't the first
famous face to Bear it all I mean it's
my face you know I I see it every
morning when I look in the mirror every
night before I go to bed and I think
if I can feel comfortable knowing that
my acne might be acting up I mean you
can even see it through my makeup
tonight yeah Charlie demilio isn't
afraid to share a fresh face post either
one Twitter user even commended The Tick
Tock star for not editing out her acne I
had originally posted it because I felt
really pretty in those pictures and I
wasn't even looking at the pimples but
then hearing other girls stories
um really really made me feel good about
it and it definitely just
concrete like proof that it's like you
just gotta really be yourself and the
more the more you can have the
confidence in yourself like people are
just going to look at you because well
if she can be confident in herself when
she has that then I can too absolutely
Kiki Palmer another star who's vocal
about her struggles I was just thinking
about the fact that plastic surgeons are
amazing okay they can give you a boob
job above the muscle under the muscle
liposuction tummy tuck BBL they can even
implant muscles I mean the list goes on
but they cannot
figure out how to clear up somebody's
skin
are you kidding me the actress has noted
in previous posts that hers is caused by
polycystic ovarian syndrome come on
let's talk about it but it seems like
Kiki's found her own remedy and it's all
tied to her recent pregnancy I found the
secret to clear into my acne and guess
what it is
you need to get Knocked Up period Point
Blank period the baby has cleared my
skin up get into the pointless I know it
look like this is I you can't tell for
real
but I need you to know it ain't never
lay flat like this your girl is ready
for the park
[Music]
foreign